dos funciones efe y que están descritas
a continuación cuando las afirmaciones
presentadas es correcta me dan efe que
está descrita como esta ecuación lineal
muy tradicional
efe entonces representa una línea recta
y tengo a g que esta gráfica da aquí
bien mis opciones son tanto f como g son
crecientes y f crece más rápido que g
pues no tenemos que g para empezar no es
una función creciente que no es una
función creciente porque mientras x se
hace más grande el valor que toma g se
hace cada vez más pequeño de hecho este
tampoco es una función creciente es una
línea con pendiente negativa sus
pendientes de menos siete tercios por lo
tanto éste también es decreciente y
puedo descartar esta opción tanto s como
g son crecientes de nuevo puedo
descartar esta inmediatamente
tanto efe como g son decrecientes y efe
de crecer más rápido kg pues veamos cuál
es la pendiente g 100 g si me paro en
este punto no muevo en una unidad hacia
la derecha entonces tengo que bajar dos
unidades para regresar a la gráfica de
modo que la pendiente que cuánto es la
pendiente es el cambio y dividido entre
el cambio en x mi cambio en x fue de 1
móvil una unidad a la derecha y mi
camión fue de -2 baje dos unidades de
modo que la pendiente que es menos 2
pero la pendiente de este es de menos 7
tercios y menos 7 tercios es lo mismo
que el número mixto menos 2 con un
tercio y menos 2 con un tercio es menor
que menos 2
así que f está decreciendo más rápido
que g
tanto efe como g son decrecientes y se
decrece más rápido que efe pues acabo de
decir que ese decrece más rápido kg por
lo tanto esta opción tampoco es correcta
y finalmente que es creciente pero efe
es decreciente que es decreciente
también así que también puede descartar
esta opción